comme tous les ans avait donc lieu hier
7 avril la réunion des délégués des
défenseurs des droits cette autorité
constitutionnelle indépendante vient en
aide depuis 2011 aux personnes victimes
de discrimination ou encore du
dysfonctionnement d'une administration
le bilan sur les actions 2015 dans le
département avec camille lambert
depuis 2011 il veille à la protection
des droits et des libertés des citoyens
ce sont les défenseurs des droits jeudi
7 avril les délégués des yvelines avait
rendez vous à la préfecture de
versailles pour un rapport d'activité de
l'année 2015 on peut constater une
stabilité du nombre de demandes et qui
sont adressés aux délégués du défenseur
des droits sur le département une
stabilité mais avec le maintien
d'une très forte demande concernant les
relations avec l'administration les
relations avec les services publics l'an
passé les défenseurs des droits du
département ont reçu près de 1540
saisine les neuf délégués chinois
travaillent de manière confidentielle et
gratuite pour informer les citoyens sur
leurs droits et les orienter toute
personne qui s'estime victime d'un
dysfonctionnement du service public ou
de discrimination peut solliciter leur
aide ce qui prédomine ce sens que
j'appelle les dossiers d'un dut c'est à
dire des demandes de remboursement par
ces organismes sociaux de sommes qui ont
été
versées alors qu'elle n'aurait pas dû
être versés et c'est souvent très
compliqué pour les personnes qui
viennent me voir en 2015 chaque délégué
yvelinois à traiter 170 dossiers en
moyenne de manière bénévole l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle permanence et d'un
nouveau délégué est prévue avant la fin
de l'année à rambouillet